hallo lara wie geht's
schön dass du gekommen bist
hallo simon mir geht's super danke
vielen dank für die einladung
ich bin schon sehr gespannt auf das
spiel
sehr gespannt auf das spiel
ja ich auch ich konnte den ganzen tag an
nichts anderes denken
komm doch rein
sag mal simon
schaust du nur fußball oder spielst du
auch gern selbst
sag mal simon
schaust du nur fußball oder spielst du
auch gern selbst
ich liebe es sowohl fußball zu schauen
als auch fußball zu spielen
früher habe ich lange fußball im verein
gespielt
mit 14 habe ich aber schmerzen im
rechten knie bekommen und musste
aufhören
mit 14 habe ich aber schmerzen im
rechten knie bekommen und musste
aufhören hätte ich keine schmerzen
gehabt wäre ich bestimmt
fußballprofi geworden
hätte ich keine schmerzen gehabt wäre
ich bestimmt
fußballprofi geworden
oh
je das tut mir sehr leid für dich oh
je das tut mir sehr leid für dich du
wirst bestimmt sehr gerne profi geworden
du wirst bestimmt sehr gerne profi
geworden
wäre ich fußballprofi geworden hätte ich
viele berühmte spieler kennengelernt
ich wäre auch viel gereist und hätte in
vielen stadien gespielt
was denkst du wer das spiel gewinnt
die rot bären natürlich
die rote beeren natürlich
wir haben ein gutes und erfahrenes team
dieses mal schaffen wir es bestimmt bis
ins viertelfinale
mit ein bisschen glück sogar bis ins
halbfinale
halbfinale und dann weiß man ja nie was
passieren kann und dann weiß man ja nie
was passieren kann
ja das stimmt turniere sind immer
unberechenbar
manchmal muss man einfach etwas glück
haben
ja weißt du wenn das turnier letztes
jahr gewesen wäre wäre ich zu allen
spielen der rot bären gegangen ja weißt
du wenn das turnier letztes jahr gewesen
wäre wäre ich zu allen spielen der rot
bären gegangen
jetzt habe ich aber einen neuen job
angefangen und kann nicht an die spiele
gehen
jetzt habe ich aber einen neuen job
angefangen und kann nicht an die spiele
gehen
ja das ist wirklich schade
ja das ist wirklich schade aber
wenigstens können wir am fernseher
mitfiebern
aber wenigstens können wir am fernseher
ja das stimmt und das in bester
gesellschaft
[Applaus]
yahoo
moment lara das tor zählt nicht es war
abseits
[Applaus]
yahoo
moment lara das tor zählt nicht es war
abseits
nein das habe ich gar nicht gesehen oh
nein das habe ich gar nicht gesehen
ich war schon im freudentaumel
schade hätte der spieler den pass eine
sekunde früher gespielt hätte das tor
gezählt
schade hätte der spieler den pass eine
sekunde früher gespielt hätte das tor
gezählt
dann hätten wir uns zusammen freuen
können dann hätten wir uns zusammen
freuen können
[Applaus]
nein
das gibt es doch nicht wie konnte das
nur passieren
nein
das gibt es doch nicht wie konnte das
nur passieren
schade aber es bleibt ja noch ein
bisschen zeit sie werden bestimmt bald
wieder ausgleichen
schade aber es bleibt ja noch ein
bisschen zeit sie werden bestimmt bald
wieder ausgleichen
das macht mich wütend hätten die
verteidiger besser aufgepasst wäre
dieses tor nie passiert das macht mich
wütend hätten die verteidiger besser
aufgepasst wäre dieses tor nie passiert
ramsan sie man abwarten und tee trinken
wie man so schön sagt
komm schon simon abwarten und tee
trinken wie man so schön sagt
ich bin so nervös ich muss ein bier
trinken
[Applaus]
oder noch besser trinkt einen shot
tequila
schüler
[Applaus]
gute idee tequila beruhigt mich sicher
oh ja gute idee tequila beruhigt mich
sicher
oh nein ich habe keinen tequila mehr
wir haben ihn letztes wochenende bei der
grillparty getrunken wir haben ihn
letztes wochenende bei der grillparty
getrunken
hätten wir diese grillparty nicht
gefeiert hätten wir die flasche tequila
nicht getrunken
hätten wir diese grillparty nicht
gefeiert hätten wir die flasche tequila
nicht getrunken
dann hätte ich jetzt etwas für meine
nerven
ja endlich ich hätte fast nicht mehr an
das tor geglaubt ja endlich ich hätte
fast nicht mehr an das tor geglaubt
siehst du simon ich habe ja gesagt dass
wir noch ein tor schießen werden jetzt
kommt gleich noch das zweite
siehst du simon ich habe dir ja gesagt
dass wir noch ein tor schießen werden
jetzt kommt gleich noch das zweite
ja du hattest recht aber wir hatten
etwas glück ja du hattest recht aber wir
hatten etwas glück wäre die
nachspielzeit nicht fünf minuten
gegangen dann hätten wir das tor nicht
vor der pause geschossen
wäre die nachspielzeit nicht fünf
minuten gegangen dann hätten wir das tor
nicht vor der pause geschossen
lara sag mal seid wann interessierst du
dich eigentlich für fußball
weißt du früher hat mich fußball 0
interessiert aber meine schwester hatte
einmal einen freund der fußballer war
weißt du früher hat mich fußball 0
interessiert
aber meine schwester hatte einmal einen
freund der fußballer war
er hat für den fc adler gespielt also
ging ich ab und zu mit ihr an die spiele
im stadion hat mich die atmosphäre total
gepackt er hat für den fc adler gespielt
also ging ich ab und somit ihr an die
spiele im stadion hat mich die
atmosphäre total gepackt seither bin ich
ein großer fußballfan
seither bin ich ein großer fußballfan
hätte meine schwester den fußballern
nicht als freund gehabt
wäre ich nie an die spiele gegangen und
hätte somit auch weiterhin kein
interesse am fußball
hätte meine schwester den fußballern
nicht als freund gehabt
wäre ich nie an die spiele gegangen und
hätte somit auch weiterhin kein
interesse am fußball
das ist interessant ich freue mich dass
der fußball gefällt
so können wir uns auch andere spiele
zusammen anschauen
ja allerdings ist es viel unterhaltsamer
dich während des spiels zu beobachten
bin ich denn so emotional
ja aber keine sorge das gefällt mir
ja da ist es was habe ich dir gesagt
ja du bist eine wahrsagerin
naja wahrsagerin nicht aber ich hatte es
im gefühl
ich habe ja schon viele spiele von den
rot bären gesehen und kenne unsere
qualitäten
ich habe ja schon viele spiele von den
rot bären gesehen und kenne unsere
qualitäten
hätte ich nicht so viele spiele gesehen
hätte ich auch nicht an den sieg
geglaubt
hätte ich nicht so viele spiele gesehen
hätte ich auch nicht an den sieg
geglaubt
ein sieg ist es noch nicht es sind ja
noch zehn minuten zu spielen
kein problem die lassen jetzt nichts
anbrennen
oh
nein was ist denn da passiert
oh nein was ist denn da passiert
das gibt's doch nicht die haben wieder
gepennt
moment schau mal der vr wird konsultiert
schau mal der vr wird konsultiert
das tor zählt nicht gott sei dank ich
habe schon die krise bekommen
hahaha ja ich habe es an einem roten
kopf bemerkt
haha ja ich habe es an einem roten kopf
bemerkt
war das knapp hätte der spieler den ball
eine sekunde früher gespielt hätte das
tor jetzt gezählt war das knapp hätte
der spieler den ball eine sekunde früher
gespielt hätte ta store jetzt gezählt ja
wir haben gewonnen
ja wir sind eine runde weiter
soso
hätten die rot bären nicht gewonnen
hättest du mich wohl nie geküsst
so so hätten die rot bären nicht
gewonnen
hättest du mich wohl nie geküsst
lara die ganz hätte zehn zu null
gewinnen können und ich hätte dich
trotzdem geschasst
lara die ganz hätte zehn zu null
gewinnen können und ich hätte dich
trotzdem geküsst
möchtest du kostenlos online deutsch
lernen
ja
wohl mit alltags gesprächen und lustigen
videos auf youtube
bei uns kannst du deinem deutsche niveau
wählen
so lernst du deutsch lektion für lektion
in der richtigen progression deutsch
lernen mit spaß
besucher jetzt unseren kanal hallo
deutsche schule